e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est j'ai acheté ma chaîne
nota passé chat il fallait passer par
moi voyons le combien as-tu payer 400
mais je t'avais dit que j'avais 50 %
chez mercier par mon copain lemercier ou
alors fallait l'acheter en angleterre
elle est homogène au match n est les
patrons collard et je les trouve moches
ah bah c'est le principal
j'espère quand même que tu as pris une
platine n ya pas mieux d'ailleurs c'est
suisse
attention le taux de pleurs âge n'est
que de 0 5%
oui mais tu as un taux de rendement de
70 db ouais enfin bref et violent et
qu'est ce que tu as appris comme ont
pris les you kaïdi
elle a pris du japonais c'est pas vrai
je me refais note bien mais il fallait
prendre un boudin avec boudin tu as deux
fois cinq ans droite efficace quoique
mais t'as pas de correcteur
physiologique et pendant 5 comme
enceinte il n'ya que j bishara tu te
rends compte que le control room monitor
à une bande passant de 20 à 20000 hertz
le rendement est dégueulasse quand vous
commencez carrément à m'emmerder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mc ce que j'ai dit c'est que je préfère
ne rien acheter tant que je peux pas
mettre le prix pour du bon matériel
c'est tout enfin l'essentiel c'est que
tu sois contente
[Musique]
mais oh